foreign
author Clint Smith is known for his
best-selling book how the word is passed
the Reckoning with the history of
slavery Across America in his new book
Smith is reflecting on a more personal
role as a dad one that I can relate to
above ground is a collection of poetry
about fatherhood and how it has changed
him some of the poems include Zoom
school with a toddler you ask me what
sound a giraffe makes and the most
remarkable thing about dinosaurs those
are some of the titles of the poems you
will find in his book Clint Smith joins
us now good morning so good to be here
with you all it is wonderful to be here
the book is absolutely wonderful it
spoke to me in so many ways you say it's
written about and with your kids how did
you put this collection together so I
started the collection when my wife got
pregnant with our first son which was a
very precarious thing we weren't sure
that we were going to get pregnant as I
write about in the book we were told we
had less than a one percent chance and
so it felt like this small miracle and
the whole process felt very uncertain
very exciting very overwhelming and so I
wanted for me poetry is the act of
paying attention and I wanted to pay
attention to how I feel I wanted to pay
attention to these moments to sort of
archive these moments and so I wrote
These poems from conception to to now
having a five-year-old and a
four-year-old as a way to sort of hold
on to these different moments ideas
things my kids said over the past
several years you paid attention big
time I mean you paid attention twice
because it goes from one baby to then
your daughter's born but glad I thought
about you because one of them is called
Ode to the first smile I I I circled
that one too because it says at first I
wasn't sure it had really happened and
then later on you say the haters say
it's too early it was probably only gas
and spasms of new muscles he came in
just the other day and said she's fine I
go oh that's gas
in your book were called haters that's
right but I like how you pick up on the
little everyday moments it happens in a
baby's life and what I really like is
the tribute you pay to your wife you
will like this Nate he said there
reasons I know I married the right
person the lovely Ariel is here by the
way because when you laugh you kind of
cackle because of the head scarves that
you wear every time I see a woman in a
headscar with different colors the way
you sing in the morning the way there
she is the way you hold my hand when I'm
scared and I don't know how to say it
the way you talk to the voice back on TV
it's just so loving and kind and you
talk about your own relationship with
your own father teaching you how to
Father Clinton yeah no absolutely so
much of being a father for me is trying
to replicate so much of what my father
did for me and it's those small moments
it's those are the poem about making
french toast with my kids on Sundays and
that's what my dad did with me and my
brother and my sister and it's in so
much apparently as you said it's not
these huge moments it's not always the
graduations the weddings day to day it's
those small things small ones would you
be able to use that velvety voice to
read this one I'd be happy to oh what
did you get what did you pick this is a
poem called Universal
my son is obsessed with space
hanging on the wall of his bedroom is a
poster of the solar system
the sun sits at the center
each of the eight planets encircle the
yellow orange orb their respective
orbits depicted by a thin white line
that makes it look as if each is being
held up in the universe by a string
when he eats a Ritz he uses his teeth to
carve the cracker into a crescent moon
then holds it above his head as if the
sky might reach down and scoop it in his
Starlet hands
he dreams of being an astronaut and a
teacher and a chef and a superhero and
the Pokemon
and I dream of his dreams and how
possible I want all of them to be
beautiful Oh I thought you were going to
talk about the Great Escape when you set
up the baby monitor and the
co-conspirators are Leo the Lion and
when those kids try to escape from the
crib it's over I know you you take us
through all the steps it's beautifully
done everybody should get this book yeah
lovely Clint Smith thank you so much for
being here everybody with children yes
above ground is on sale now wherever you
like to buy books